in the last video we defined internal
energy as literally all the energy
that's in a system it's kind of the most
inclusive version at least in my head so
that's my system it's some type of
container and i have a bunch of
particles in here it's literally the sum
of the kinetic energies of all these
particles if they had potential energies
we'd throw that in there if they have
electrical potential we'd throw that in
in there if they have bonds with each
other the energies in that bond we would
throw in there it's everything it's all
inclusive and you know it's i told you
in the last video it's unintuitive that
u stands for internal energy but i kind
of think you know you it contains the
universe of energies and you know that's
just for me to memorize it don't think
too deeply into what i just said but
this is internal energy
internal energy if you show me a system
and if you show me a system it has some
internal energy it's a function of its
state i don't care how it got to that
state but if you told me a system in a
certain state maybe with a certain
pressure a certain volume or at a
certain temperature although if you give
me pressure and volume that should be
enough i can tell you what its internal
energy is or if you especially if you
tell me the type of molecule i have and
things like that now we also said in the
last video that because internal energy
is all the energy of the system it can't
be it can't be randomly created or
destroyed it can just be transformed
from one
from one form to another so if i have a
change in internal energy so if i have a
change in internal energy it can only be
due to well it can be due to more than
what i'm describing but in our simple
world where all of the energy in a
system and maybe we're dealing with
gases because that's normally what you
deal with in a first year chemistry
course it's going to be the heat that
could be added to the system
plus the work done on the system
plus the work done on the system and
like i said in the last video sometimes
they'll say instead of plus the work
done on the system sometimes they say
minus the syst
the work that the system does either way
and here i just want to make another
side
side let me discussion here because i
decided to write it without the little
deltas here and the reason why i did
that is if you were to write this
equation which you will see you'll see
it in textbooks teachers will do it
nothing inherently criminal about that
but i just do that because
it clears in my mind what heat and what
work are relative to internal energy if
i were to write
delta
u is equal to
heat
delta q
plus
delta w
to me this implies
that at some point i had some amount of
heat in my system and then i have a
different amount of heat in my system
and i took the difference between the
two and i got a change in heat so this
implies that heat is somehow an inherent
an inherent macro state of the system
and that's not the case i cannot look at
this system until i could tell you how
much i can tell you what the internal
energy of this system is i can tell you
it's pressure i can tell you it's volume
i can tell you it's temperature these
are all macro states of the system i
don't know how it got to this situation
but i can tell you about it i cannot
tell you what the heat is of this system
and that might be a little unintuitive
because if i tell you
you know if i ask you hey i have a cup
of coffee what's the heat of it you
might say oh it's you know you might
give me the temperature because in our
everyday language we use things like
heat and temperature interchangeably but
in thermodynamics heat is a transfer of
energy a way to think about it is
if internal energy is your bank account
right so you could say change in bank
account
change in bank account change in
bank
change in bank account and it really is
like the bank the energy bank account of
a system if you have a change in a bank
account that's you you had some deposits
or withdrawals and heat and work are
really just deposits or withdrawals into
our energy bank account heat is one kind
maybe heat is like a wire transfer so
you could say it's wire transfer
wire transfers
to your account
transfers to your account plus
i don't know plus
check deposits i'm just you know i'm
just plus check deposits
now it wouldn't make sense it makes a
lot of sense to say you could say what
is my value of my bank account or you
could say what is my change in my bank
account you take two snapshots of your
bank account at two different times but
would it make sense to say
you know i could say i wire transferred
ten dollars right so i could say i could
say
this statement would be plus
ten dollars and i could say that i wrote
twenty dollars in checks
minus twenty dollars in checks in which
case my change in my bank account would
be minus ten dollars
now would it make sense for me to say
change in wire transfer that implies
that when i started off maybe my bank
account had a hundred dollars in it
and now it has 90.
when it when my bank account had 109
dollars in it did it have any wire
transfer amount no wire transfer was how
money ex was was deposited or taken away
from my account likewise it didn't have
a checking deposit account so i can't
really it just seems weird to me to say
change in wire transfer is 10 or change
in check deposit is twenty dollars or
minus twenty dollars what you say is i
made a ten dollar wire transfer and i
and i paid twenty dollars in check so i
had a net change in my bank account of
ten dollars likewise i say how much work
was done to me or i did which is
essentially a deposit or withdrawal
of energy or i could say how much heat
was given to me or how much heat was
released which is another way of
depositing or withdrawing energy from my
energy bank account so that's why i like
to stick to this
and i like to stay away from this
and like just like i said you can't say
how much heat is in the system so
someone will say oh how much heat isn't
that you cannot say that there's no heat
state variable for that system you have
internal energy the closest thing to
heat we'll talk about in a future video
is enthalpy enthalpy is essentially a
way of measuring how much heat is in a
system but we won't talk about that just
now and you can't say how much work is
in a system
you can't say oh i have x amount of work
in a system the system can do work or
have work done to it but there is not a
certain amount of work because that
energy in the system could could be all
used for work it could all be used for
heat it could all be used for a ton of
different things so you can't say those
things and that's why i don't like
treating them like state variables or
state functions so with that said
this is our definition let's do a couple
of
simple problems just to give you
intuition and i really want to give you
make you comfortable
my real goal is to make you comfortable
with you know when to know to use plus
or minus on the work and
the best way to do it is not to memorize
the formula but just to kind of think
about what's happening
so let's say that i have some system
here and it's a balloon and let's say
that i have no change in internal let's
say i have no change in internal energy
internal energy is zero and for our
purposes we can kind of view it as the
kinetic energy of the particles haven't
changed
and let's say by expanding a bit
by my balloon expanding a bit i did some
work i'll do this in more detail in the
next video
but let's say i do
so the system does
system does
10
joules
of work
my question is how much heat was added
or taken away from the system
how much heat
was added or taken away
so the way i could think about you don't
even have to write the formula down or
you can write it you could say look
the internal energy the amount of energy
in the system hasn't changed the system
did 10 joules of work
so that's energy going out of the system
it did 10 joules so 10 joules went out
in the form of work
if the internal energy did not change
then some energy then essentially 10
joules of energy had to go into the
system
10 joules had to go into the system if
it didn't the internal energy would have
gone down by the amount of work we had
so
10 joules and the only way if this is
the net work the only way that we're
talking about that we can add energy
outside of work is through heat so 10
joules of heat must have been added so
we can write 10
joules of heat
10 joules of heat added
added to system now let's look at that
from the point of view of the actual
formula if we have delta u
is equal to
is equal to
heat added
plus work done to the system
then we would say okay this was zero
it's equal to
the heat added to the system
remember in this way we're saying this
is the heat done or the work done to the
system right w is work done
now the system did work to something
else it didn't have work done to it to
it
so if the if if this is work done to the
system and it did work then this is
going to be a minus 10
minus 10 joules and then you solve both
sides of this you add 10 to both sides
and you get
you get
10 is equal to q
which is exactly what we got up here but
this can get confusing sometimes because
you're like oh did work get you know is
this heat that the system did is this
the heat
is this heat that was added to the
system or taken away the ten the
convention is all tends to be that this
is heat added
heat added but then sometimes it's
confusing is this the work done to the
system or work done by and that's why i
like just doing it this way if the
system does work it loses energy if the
system has work done to it it gains
energy so let's do another problem
i mean i could have done this exact same
thing using the other formula you'll
sometimes see
delta u is equal to
q
minus
the work that the system does
does by the system done by the system
work done by the system and in this case
once again change in internal energy was
zero that is equal to
heat added to the system
minus the work done
so minus i told you at the beginning of
the problem that the system did
10 joules of work so minus the work done
minus 10 joules we get the same
situation up here from two different
formulas and we got
10 is equal to q either way the heat
added to the system is 10 joules
let's do one more let's say that
i don't know
q like let's i don't know let's say five
joules
of heat
heat taken away from system taken away
from
system
and let's say that
one joule of work done on system done on
system so maybe we're compressing the
balloon
on the system
what is our change in internal energy or
let's say that our well let's just
figure out our change
so the way i think of it is five joules
of heat taken away from the system
that's going to reduce our internal
energy by minus five
and if one joule of work is done onto
the system we're putting energy into it
so that'll be plus one
so minus five plus one
is going to be minus four or enter our
change in internal energy is minus four
joules now we could have done that a
little bit more formally
with the formula
change in internal energy is equal to
heat added to the system
plus
work
done on the system
work done on the system so it's equal to
heat added to the system we had five
joules heat taken away so this is minus
five
plus work done on the system
we have one joule of work done on the
system
and there we get once again
minus four now i could have written that
same formula the other way i could have
said change in internal energy
is equal to heat added to the system
minus the work that the system does i
want to do this both ways because i
don't want to get confused either way
you see it in in
on problems or in school or maybe you
take one class that does it one way and
one class that does the other if you use
it this way
what was the heat added to the system we
had heat taken away so it's minus five
so minus the work that the system does
how much this work does the system
do
well the system
had one joule of work done to it
so did it did itself minus one joules of
work
right so it's minus minus one i want to
be clear when i use this formula this is
system
this is work done by system done by
this is work done to
done to
the system had work done to it so it had
minus one were joules of work done by
the system so these become pluses and
you get back to a minus four do whatever
is intuitive for you for me this tends
to be the most intuitive where you don't
even use the formula where you just
think if i'm doing work i'm using up
energy if i get work done to me i'm
being handed over energy if i have heat
taken away from me i'm giving away
energy if i have heat added to me i have
i'm getting energy see in the next video